if the path before you is clear
you're probably on someone else's
everything that irritates us about
others
can lead us to an understanding of
ourselves
where your fear is
there is your task
if a man knows more than others
he becomes lonely
thinking is difficult
that's why most people judge
even a happy life cannot be without a
measure of Darkness
and the word happy would lose its
meaning if it were not balanced by
sadness
children learn by an adult's example
not by their words
you are what you do
not what you say you'll do
what did you do as a child that made the
hours pass like minutes
herein lies the key to your Earthly
Pursuits
the shoe that fits one person pinches
another
there is no recipe for living that suits
all cases
[Music]
for better to come good must stand aside
the greatest tragedy of the family is
the unlived lives of the parents
you are not what happened to you
you are what you chose to become
to ask the right question is already
half the solution of a problem
the privilege of a lifetime is to become
who you truly are
man needs difficulties
they are necessary for health
the soul needs your recklessness not
your wisdom
loneliness does not come from having no
people about one
but from being unable to communicate the
things that seem important to oneself
or from holding certain views which
others find inadmissible
he was afraid needs dependence
as a weakened man needs support
life really does begin at 40.
up until then
you are just doing research
if you are a gifted person
it doesn't mean you got something
it means you can give something away
people will do anything no matter how
absurd to avoid facing their own Souls
the least of things with the meaning is
worth more in life than the greatest of
things without it
shame is a soul-eating emotion
your vision will become clear only when
you can look into your own heart
who looks outside dreams who looks
inside awakes
midlife is the time to let go of an over
dominant ego and to contemplate the
deeper significance of human existence
every form of addiction is bad
no matter whether the narcotic is
alcohol morphine
or idealism
wholeness is not achieved by cutting off
a portion of one's being
but by integration of the contraries
we were born at a given moment in a
given place
and like vintage years of wine
we have the qualities of the year and of
the season in which we are born
until you make the unconscious conscious
it will direct your life
and you will call it fate
foreign
does not torture others
generally it is the tortured who turn
into torturers
a man who has not passed through The
Inferno of his Passions
has never overcome them
people grow like plants
some in light others in shade
there are many who need shade not light
we cannot change anything until we
accept it
condemnation does not liberate
it oppresses
woe to those who live by examples
there is no life in them
if you live by example you live the life
of that example
but who will live your life but yourself
so live your own life
man cannot stand a meaningless life
shrinking away from death is something
unhealthy and abnormal
which robs the second half of Life of
its purpose
where love rules there is no Will To
Power and where power predominates love
is lacking
the one is the shadow of the other
the greatest and most important problems
of Life are all fundamentally insoluble
they can never be solved but only
outgrown
man can endure the hardest trials if he
sees meaning in them
the whole difficulty lies in creating
that meaning
what we walk away from shying away from
ostensibly forgetting is dangerously
close to us
and eventually it will return
but with redoubled Force
knowing your own darkness is the best
method for dealing with the darkness of
other people
in each of us there is another whom we
do not know
depression is Like a Woman in Black
if she turns up don't shoo her away
invite her in offer her a seat treat her
like a guest and listen to what she
wants to say
where wisdom Reigns there is no conflict
between thinking and feeling
knowledge rests not upon truth alone
but upon error also
every human life contains a potential
if that potential is not fulfilled
then that life was wasted
[Music]
if an attractive woman is single it's
because she's smarter than everyone else
the meeting of two personalities is like
the contact of two chemical substances
if there is any reaction both are
transformed
don't hold on to anyone who's leaving
otherwise you won't meet the one who's
coming
don't rush to help those who haven't
asked you to
because not everyone who is drowning
needs a hand
some want to drown
most people consider themselves very
knowledgeable in Psychology for one
simple reason psychology for them comes
down to what they know about themselves
has any change must begin somewhere it
is the single individual who will
undergo it and carry it through
the change must begin with one
individual
it might be any one of us
nobody can afford to look around and to
wait for somebody else to do what he is
loathed to do himself
we have chosen these quotes from Carl
Jung which we hope will help you
understand yourself better he was one of
the first psychologists who introduced
the idea of analytical psychology and
popularized it to the world thank you
for watching this video